as we've seen in other videos this is a
map of the european possessions
especially the western european
possessions in much of the world as we
enter into the 20th century before world
war one
you see significant possessions by the
french not just in africa but also in
indochina
you see the british also have
significant possessions in africa but
also in asia germany belgium italy also
have imperial possessions
now as we go through world war one that
changes the map of europe fairly
dramatically and we talk about that in
other videos but some of the major
outcomes at least when we're talking
about imperialism is that the
austro-hungarian empire gets broken up
changing the map of eastern europe
the ottoman empire gets broken up with
much of the middle east now under
control by the british or french and of
course russia exits world war one having
had the bolshevik revolution in 1917 and
is now the soviet union as we get into
the period after world war one we start
to see
momentum gather in terms of independence
movements in terms of this imperial
structure breaking down
in
1922 egypt becomes independent of the
united kingdom
iraq which was part of the ottoman
empire for centuries was put under
british control after world war one and
in 1932 it gets its independence then we
enter into world war ii which is an
incredibly traumatic time not just for
europe but for the world and as we exit
out of world war ii we see further
momentum being gained for the various
anti-colonial independence movements
indonesia which was originally a dutch
colony but during world war ii gets
under the control of japan as part of
its imperial possessions but as we get
into august of 1945
the japanese are bombed at hiroshima and
nagasaki effectively ending world war ii
and the indonesians are able to claim
their independence nominally now from
the dutch
then from 1944 to 1946
further possessions that were originally
part of the ottoman empire but after
world war one became under the control
of the french and british syria and
jordan gained their independence syria
from france and jordan from united
kingdom and then in 1947
you have the independence of the indian
subcontinent
this is a particularly noteworthy
struggle under the leadership of
mahandis gandhi often known as mahatma
gandhi mahatma meaning great soul and
it's a peaceful resistance that's able
to get independence now the subcontinent
is partitioned into what will become
pakistan and india for the most part
areas that were majority muslim became
pakistan and you could see this region
in the west and this region the east
which would later get its independence
in 1971 and become bangladesh and then
for the most part regions that had hindu
majorities became india this wasn't a
clean partition because there were some
territories princely states areas where
the majority was not clear that became
under contention kashmir even to this
day is a point of contention between
india and pakistan much of the indian
subcontinent was very mixed with some
areas being 60 hindu or 40 muslim or
vice versa so that catalyzed one of the
largest migrations in human history the
number of people changing borders
sometimes becoming quite sectarian and
quite bloody but even after that india
is still one of the largest muslim
countries the founder of pakistan is
muhammad ali jinnah and india's first
prime minister and both of them were
active in the independence movement is
jarvar halal nehru who will become
famous for the non-aligned movement for
newly liberated countries to not want to
side on either side of the cold war and
he actually coins the term third world
which is now associated with developing
countries but when it was coined it
meant we don't want to be first world
aligned with the western capitalist
countries we don't want to be second
world aligned with the communist bloc we
want to be independent or the third
world
as we get into the late 40s and early
50s we also see an independence movement
in french indochina
these countries will eventually become
north vietnam south vietnam laos and
cambodia and a significant figure here
is ho chi minh who will become a very
prominent figure as the french indochina
war eventually evolves into the vietnam
war bringing the united states into it
as part of its cold war containment
strategy the 1950s also see significant
independence movements throughout africa
in 1951 libya gains independence from
1956 to 1958
tunisia morocco ghana guinea all gained
independence
a particular note is ghana originally
called gold coast the first president
and prime minister is kwame nakrumah and
he's known as one of the founders of the
organization of african unity and he
wanted to see a world where as these
african countries became independent
they unified seeing that africa would
have much more power as a unified entity
than as a fragmented one and so he was a
major promoter of the idea of
pan-africanism now the independence
movements only accelerated as we go into
the 1960s
1960 in particular was a year of many
independence movements but you can see
here most of africa was independent as
we exit the 1960s
in blue here listed the
french colonies that gained independence
in this time period in this salmon color
the the british colonies and in yellow
the belgian colonies there would
continue to be change over the next few
decades but the world starts to look
very similar to the world as we
recognize it today now i'll leave you
with a speech that jawahar halal nehru
made in washington dc in 1956
which highlights his desire for
non-alignment
the preservation of peace forms the
central aim of india's policy it is in
the pursuit of this policy that we have
chosen the path of non-alignment in any
military or like pact of alliance
non-alignment does not mean passivity of
mind or action lack of faith or
conviction it does not mean submission
to what we consider evil it is a
positive and dynamic approach to such
problems that confront us
we believe that each country has not
only the right to freedom but also to
decide its own policy and way of life
and this is a big deal because remember
he's giving the speech in washington dc
which would love him to clearly align
with the western bloc with the
capitalist countries led by the united
states but after working so hard for
their independence many of these nations
like india were not eager to lose their
autonomy and realign with more powerful
countries to close out this video i'll
leave you with a an interesting question
or a series of interesting
questions why do we see a good chunk of
the world become independent in the
second half of the 20th century
was it that the imperial countries no
longer had the energy or the power or
the will to control these colonies
was it something happened in the
psychology of their peoples they just
went through a traumatic war and they
realized that they weren't interested in
controlling the destiny of other people
was it due to the efficacy of some of
these independent struggles like the
non-violence movement led by gandhi or
maybe some of the more violent
independent struggles like what we saw
in algeria against the french
but needless to say the world
fundamentally changed in this time
period when we were entering into the
20th century we had an imperial world
especially controlled by the western
european powers
after two traumatic wars imperialism
comes to an end and we see the world as
we know it today